I just want to be me I want to be taken
seriously as an artist and media trans
girl the same time to look you can do oh
yeah hair with in my opinion the queen
of poppies are great now thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]
you are crushing it really an honor for
me to be sitting here with you backstage
at the Fonda your headlining tour the
broken tour what does this all feel like
to you
unreal yeah it's really me it means my
first tour ever and it sold out so fast
I couldn't like believe it my team was
freaking out I was freaking out and it's
been really incredible so far just
seeing my pants every day it's been a
lot as well but it's been really
incredible I mean you just said you know
you're freaking out that it's a sold-out
tour but yes that's gotta be a little
expected at this point your music isn't
resonating with fans and people are so
dedicated your funds are so dedicated to
you thank you have you adjusted to this
new level of Fame that you have in your
life now yeah yeah for sure I mean I I
just I love what I do and it doesn't
feel it doesn't really feel different
like I mean whenever I meet a fan I'm
like really friendly yeah okay I feel
like my fans are my friends so I don't
really feel like anything's like changed
for me that's so obviously because I
imagine things in your life have changed
what would you say is the biggest
difference I mean it's it's more and
more and more but sometime like I love
it you know I've always wanted to do
this so I love it when it happens um but
yeah probably the biggest change is just
that I don't have any time to do
anything anymore like it's just job job
job but I've always wanted to be this
way so what do you feel like has gone on
the back burner it's like work is really
on the rise like what it's had to kind
of take a backseat everything yeah like
what like my relationship like I mean
this whole record is a breakup record
it's pretty like the T is out there
personal life important to you at this
point right now for me is go time like I
kind of only tried to call my mom as
much as possible try to keep my family
updated but it's really like definitely
like on the back burner on purpose
because like I've been working towards
this like moment about actually breaking
my whole entire life so yeah it's all
that I care about right now yeah well
the moment is here your fans are lined
up around the block thank you what can
someone expect if they come out to the
broken torch oh it's really fun it's
very high-energy my fans are really high
energy they scream every single airing
it's everything I wanted it to be for
the first time I've been a supporting
act a lot before for other people I've
done a bunch of clubs for years and
years and years I'm kind of like that
that that Lady Gaga mean that's like
another close another close romanika
club another club another club another
club that's me right now
[Applause]
it's the first time the stage looks how
I wanted to look present my visuals and
screens which is really cool I know
people who are fans of you you give us
the box you make us dance like you just
put us in such a good mood I want to
know are there any emotional moments in
your show yeah for sure I mean this
whole new record
I just dropped clarity has a lot of
emotional songs on it I've broken all I
just cry if you think about me is always
feeling emotional
yeah for sure yeah I've cried on stage
before on this tour
not on this tour okay no few minutes ago
yet I mean I mean I should my songs got
all I do is cry oh yeah I love that
[Music]
do you have a favorite lyrics off of the
clarity projects hope you happy with
your new [ __ ] how you live in I'm in
Paris in Marc Jacobs life's amazing hope
you're happy with your new [ __ ]
are you living I'm in Paris then tell me
where that lyric was birthed from like
when you're sitting there writing where
did that come out of your brain um I was
just like trying to make a breakup song
fun and find an angle that's not
depressing in a breakup and being
cheated on which sucks and that angle is
that I work really hard my you know my
entire life I I have a career now and
like I feel really proud of that and I'm
like my lips are moving now and I get to
where Marc Jacobs and you don't the
person who you wrote that about know
that that songs about that the aperture
do you have a reaction from them do you
know how they feel about it no I feel
like oh I won't get that ya know it was
a very like a break revenge is the
sweetest success on the timeline or I'm
sure is you know doing the job
you've been such an incredible voice for
the entire LGBTQ community talk to me
about your role as an advocate and why
that's so important to you sure I'm well
I'm transgender I'm part of the
community I feel like I was born and
raised in a gay club playing all my
friends are gay I don't want to go to
gay clubs ever like my first whole era
was dedicated to writing gay club
classics which I oh yeah of course and I
just feel really passionate about the
transgender kids and transgendered
people in general because I was one of
them it was pretty hard and um it's a
hard thing to go through and the hard
thing to go to school with there's a
very high suicide rate
it's very latest time and I just really
care deeply I think it comes across and
everything that you do that you care and
everything you do is so genuine how do
you strike the balance between I want to
support and I want to be that voice for
the community but like I'm all soaked in
Petra's that I'm a boss and I'm an
artist they don't create it how do you
deal with it it's been hard um in the
beginning I I didn't want to make a big
deal out of it because I know that it
quickly overshadows everything else
becomes the only thing people want to
talk about and that's really annoying
and then you have people saying you're
using your identity your sexuality to
get to places and you don't deserve it
and you haven't worked for it so it's a
very hard balance to strike but that was
the reason that my first covers of the
music didn't have my face on them nobody
knew I was transgender and my first song
still went to number one on the global
viral channel Spotify and I didn't talk
about in interviews like I really did
almost to just like not mention it at
all and still managed to like you know
make my career and that had nothing to
do with it but a lot of people were
saying oh she doesn't care about us and
that's so far from the truth and it
sucks
hearing that and it was really hurtful
at the same time that people thought I
didn't want to be an advocate
or trans people so um no I don't care
what whatever people say people say I'm
using my story to get places or people
say whatever they want about me like I
want to be a voice for transgender
people and that's really close to my
heart and I feel like I've done the part
where I under play it and you know make
it all about the music and I just want
to be me and at the same time make music
and I want to be taken seriously as an
artist and um be a trans girl at the
same time you know you can do both oh
yes what Taylor Swift is doing right now
I think she's such a big huge massive
mainstream pop star with such a broad
base that it's amazing that she chose to
support us I think it's great that's
that you know right now being gay or
being an advocate is lucrative for
people like that's amazing
it used to be like the opposite for like
yes always it always used to be the
opposite it just started that people are
saying oh you know you can like you know
gays have money to like they buy stuff
you know like I I don't I don't see it
as something negative and I don't think
that she's doing it because of that
reason of 82 carats I think she has
friends that are gay and I think it's
amazing that she's finally like standing
up for gay rights as well I just think
we need to be me to treat people better
and with more acceptance and make a
community and just accept anybody who
wants to support us because it's been
like a long way to go for the LGBTQ
community we've come really far but
still like we should we should take
anything we should get we can get I
think so I think I want to [ __ ] from
Taylor Swift to another pop star that
you're very close with miss Paris Hilton
oh yes
[Music]
first of all talking about your
friendship with her and why is she your
favorite well she's like the sweetest
baby Angel okay literally the sweetest
person I've ever met in my life
I used to be really obsessed with the
pimple I really can't there's like these
there's these pictures with like me like
standing in front of my wall with hat
which I like a bunch of Paris Hilton
pictures on it she also has seen that
feature which is awesome oh just so
awesome but my my first song I don't
want it at all this very inspired for
her and she chose to be in the video and
I was nothing it was my first song and
tiny budget techne dressing room
you know just back down but she was like
I love the song so much I'm gonna be in
the music video so it sparked a
friendship are you like text yeah with
Paris like yeah that's it yeah I went to
a birthday what we always text we always
like each other stuff where she's gonna
support us and really great well yeah
being friends with you I think has it
I've been in the closet oh god how is
that being friends with you has its
perks because you're a brilliant
songwriter thank you we're waiting for
the day when you give Paris with a Kim
Petrus signature banger is it in the
worst the officer I'm always thinking
about it I promise it to have to do it
so um yeah you haven't written anything
left out I think I have some ideas and
smooth starts but no no I want to start
up a song and then and then let her over
and then do it okay and then have her
lay down yeah
could it ever be a duet between it's
compacter so down
you've got so much going on right now
but I imagine you have so many things
you still want to accomplish oh yeah
what are your top three goals that you'd
like to get into motion with and maybe
the next big year oh I'm gonna go on
more tourists I'm named a European legs
then I'm gonna come back I think end of
this year in America um do a even bigger
tour I'm gonna drop my second Halloween
EP I have a lot of music to finish that
I want to talk I want to do a bunch of
music videos and I mean my like all-time
goal it's probably to play a medicine
scribe right in like that's just like my
goal and I've learned to like not have
any expectations and I can set no timing
expectations think I want to get there
whatever happens happens
like that's just like try to live by
sure cuz I don't wanna get
disappointment by my own stuff that I
like makeup and like things that I said
like I mama on my way to like great
things I feel and I'm really proud of
what I've done so far outside but I was
gonna take a step further your fans who
are showing up to the broken tour how do
you hope they feel when they leave the
show what is the big message or takeaway
that you want people to feel well my
number one thing pop for me as a kid as
a kid in the middle of nowhere Germany
going to school was one I hated school I
hated my life pretty hard I mean I'm
transgender and I was like doing
documentaries in Germany about being
trans in there so I got back and I felt
like I hated my life enough and I went
home and I watched when Stefani's love
angel music baby music videos and forgot
about my problems and Britney meet with
music videos and pop for me Papa Mia's
been like an escape from my life from my
problems so that's what I wanted to do
for my parents so I hope they can just
like be free and forget about their
problems and have the best night of your
life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]